bernard lachance et au sommet de ces
belles arnaques les mêmes accueillis par
oprah winfrey la grande dame de la
télévision américaine
pendant un bref moment il est tard et
semble parti pour la gloire mais douze
ans plus tard sa vie avait pris une
toute autre tournure très bien nommé
cette vidéo a été filmée 11 jours avant
que bernard lachance ne meurt à l'âge de
46 ans ce message est destiné à son ami
e gaulle ville un ex médecin français
qui offre des soins non conventionnelles
le scoop c'est que de mon point de vue
les virus n'existe pas en réponse à
l'appel à l'aide de bernard lachance
hugo levés lui conseille de boire 3
litres d'eau salée par jour en
l'assurant que ce régime allait rétablir
son système digestif
wajdi disent que les gens vivent bernard
lachance était séropositif mais ils
n'avaient plus confiance dans la
médecine moderne
à la grande déception de lempire
politico pharmaceutique qui était en
2007 il avait cessé sa trithérapie
ce protocole pharmaceutique qui donne
aux personnes séropositives une
espérance de vie presque normale
au total a opté sans rêver dollars aux
contribuables
mais quelques années plus tard sa mort
est l'aboutissement de quelques amis qui
vont bouleverser son entourage un
parcours qui l'a plongée dans l'univers
dé compléter lui même issu bernard
lachance qui lui aussi c'est con que
convertit d'alec conspirationnistes et
le complète ce soir c'est en 2017 que
bernard lachance commencent à
s'intéresser à des personnages contre
vérifie il y en a qui croient encore que
le sida est contagieux
c'est la plus grande imposture du siècle
ghislaine lanctôt est très connu dans le
milieu de la médecine alternative
médecins des chu ne croit pas à la
pandémie de l'aco vide et au vih
au vaccin c'est pas vrai qu'on a besoin
de manger de loi pour sauver quelques
mois après avoir découvert les théories
ghislaine lanctôt
bernard lachance arrête sa trithérapie
pour cela je vais parler mais c'est une
dame
j'adore c'est une amie elle me racontait
justement entendu parler de ça la fraude
a suivi pendant la pandémie
bernard lachance devient une vedette du
monde conspirationnistes avec des propos
qui font souvent écho à ceux de
ghislaine lanctôt le vih n'a jamais été
isolée et démontré dans le centre de
personnes qui ont tous un test qu'on dit
positif moi qui se pose est d'après le
ms et big pharma d'avoir 2 milliards de
virus dans mon sens on peut pas montrer
york ait vous plusieurs proches du
chanteur dans ses serres nous raconte
avoir dû couper les pompes car sa
nouvelle obsession prenait toute la
place
quand il est tombé lara il ne parlait
que de ce que de feu il se nourrissait
de fausses informations
moi j'ai j'ai la certitude que bernard
s'est fait manipuler
pendant ces derniers mois bernard
lachance ne se sentait pas bien
il avait tenté de se soigner à l'aide de
divers produits naturels qui lui avait
été recommandé par son amie amélie poehl
aujourd'hui on parle de samson dans les
médias chanteuse et youtube heures à
milipol se dit aussi tenace europa elle
est également représentante de vente
pour une marque de produits naturels sur
laquelle bernard lachance avait dépensé
des milliers de dollars qu il faisait
traitements naturels avec de l'eau salée
des électrodes pour traiter 56 actuelle
sa diarrhée sa perte de poids est aussi
il y avait un autre but c'était de faire
un genre de désintoxication 2
des médicaments qui avait pris à trois
amis quatre ans les médicaments contre
le sida michel martel était un ami de
longue date de bernard lachance médecin
il avait lui aussi pris ses distances
depuis quelques années il lui a rendu
visite
onze jours avant son décès je trouve sa
phénoménale phénoménal que ces gens là
le voyait en facetime puis qu'il disait
dans ce programme va te donner des
muscats naturel ben ses preuves
c'est triste parce que c'est
complètement je dire cherche le mot
profiter profitez du liberia soudan
maillot douce réjean thomas est une
sommité dans le domaine du vih c'est
aussi l'ancien médecin de bernard
lachance l'on veut mourir ou à lille en
vue des pays riches de continuer de
purger des gens et faire boire de l'eau
salée des choses comme ça demain avec
les entraînements il fera encore ici ce
sens à la question pourquoi bernard est
allé vers ces gens 20 au lieu de venir
vers vers la science que ça pouvait
impliquer dans un courriel huggel a
affirmé qu'il n'avait faire que des
conseils gratuits à son ami bernard
lachance et que ce dernier n'aurait
jamais accepté d'être hospitalisée à
milipol n'a pas donné suite à notre
demande d'entrevue
mais dans une vidéo elle dit que bernard
lachance était inébranlable
mais personne n'aurait pu et veut quoi
faire sergo intelligent ghislaine
lanctôt n'a pas répondu à nos questions
quelques jours après notre premier
courriel
elle a filmé cette vidéo on va dire que
c'est suspect
la manière dont il est mort était une
grande famille bernard avait peur il
était comme dans une fois lille il n'y
avait pas que
gouvernement ou le big pharma ça
débarrasse de lui et avait peur de ça il
sera dépôt compte que ceux de qui aurait
dû avoir passé ce qu'ils appelaient à
l'aide